[Music]
this week we've got a mall rental
hashtag a free Britney and it's Breaking
Bad oh wow these are all very
interesting except for the first one I
care about the last mall rental that's
not I mean think about that
imagine if you rinse it out Westfield
Culver City like for like a day now
because I even be more into like whole
mall okay and okay in all fairness you
have a beautiful accent but I thought
you said more rental pretty fun
alright so this guy in Saudi Arabia he
booked an entire mall yeah yeah for head
like seriously for him and his boy just
like drive around and go shop the shop
so drive
yeah do the driving side of the mall um
maybe maybe no maybe my car people
cannot show me so there's ample there's
a video of it and like McLaren maybe the
video is kind of like simple okay
a camel can you tilt it down a little
bit oh it's a Aston Martin I think it is
it's one of the other or Audi is that
Audi Oh fun
and then like you don't know I'm far
away I'm far away stop you ought to tell
you I'm just a hater he's really just
trying to flex like this is all about
the P we got enough space to write
pottery shopping I'm a car person he
doesn't even have enough space to put in
a car that's after Martin so you go up
the escalator floor the loading elevator
is a cog Oh foot lake Barney there's
always cars in the mall you get the
Sweepstakes thing but never on the top
never on the oh yeah three levels first
maybe that malls just something else cuz
I've heard that the malls in the Middle
East are like next [ __ ] level oh so I
saw this video and I was like oh
whatever this guy is trying to flex is
just kind of whatever and then when I it
said like what the mall was and I saw an
actual picture of it oh my
he brings out a section he rented out
the whole mall and so every employee was
still there getting paid regularly and
like he just paid out whatever he wanted
like customers that day do some
Christmas shopping or something hey he
could've rented it out on December 24th
that it could have been but I think what
else is funny is that like it's not even
like he brought like his wife there and
like family and like everyone just went
around shopping like no it was literally
a well appears to be just him and his
boy you know who else did that Michael
Jackson he's copying Michael Jackson
he's not the first to do you did that a
whole mall I heard about the grocery
store well it was a grocery store inside
of them all - mm-hmm
but he would he would do it so how do
you catch just once but all the time
yeah like this is the fee I'm trying to
think like how much do you think it
would cost you you know business what if
you owned a mall what would uh I don't
know I don't know I don't know mall
business you're like good at business
and I think the most qualified out of
all the ballers they don't like so I
think us common peasants we work from
the bottom up like for example by
calculating our wages
how many hours are open it's not even
like a mind like this for them to like
there's a billion dollar solve it like
right we can make up the father's shoots
high and then bring it down yeah yeah a
trillion dollars make you shut the [ __ ]
up
so the grocery store thing for Michael
Jackson it wasn't because I here's that
mega rich people are the stingiest
people yeah yeah also what they want
they also want to get what they want
more than anything
yeah I don't know any so I can't say but
for Michael Jackson his friend was the
grocery store the store owner that's
interesting friends also giving his
friend money though too so like I feel
like it cuz it'll come back around
because he owe me now that's what I
would be thinking you know yeah like you
say like a drive-through when you go to
the food court and stuff you know I bet
that's a little bit then it goes
I know that's what I was picturing
drive-through shopping I wonder how much
it cost to run a mall period like a
daily cost but that one I want to know
that one okay do you think that it cost
him let's say six hours do you think
that it was under or over a million
dollars no have you have it no I don't
have the number I'm just guessing huge
they showed it cost like millions like
like eight figures or some insane amount
a day yeah just to like launch off those
fireworks - it's like a [ __ ] ton of
money my favorite part about that is I
know some rich [ __ ] came in and
was like oh yeah so I would like to rent
out Disneyland for day they were like
alright here's the price now never mind
somebody's trying to do that before I
came in big ballin like probably
somebody from like Saudi Arabia and then
they're like mm I don't know they got
crazy money they do it's like there are
VIP people though like Justin Bieber has
been in dissing them by himself I don't
know how they do it I know the ice uh I
think Obama's family's been in there by
themselves
really maybe it's like good promotion II
don't know if it's a money thing it
might just be like a cloud game like a
slot Oh grab night there right yeah
that's true so they just make more money
then yeah see actually when you think
about it so since Disneyland has those
like shutdown days or it's like they
have different levels of passes they are
they already got people's money for the
damn season pass you know like they
they're still bringing in money for that
day cumulative Lee so they could afford
to just be like alright let's save a
little shutdown some areas of the park
oh bombers are coming it might not even
be that much it might like the idea of
it it's probably worth more than Y
actually is I know I can't even remember
for sure but I think I heard that st.
Jude's Hospital cost like 1.3 million
dollars a day like to run I or maybe
more than that maybe it was like 11
million I don't know it's like some
crazy no don't be surprised yeah because
it's huge and and how many doctors are
there and they're already getting like
half a million dollars or some [ __ ]
those Disney singers they make money you
know they really do they gotta pay them
Disney six eggs Disney singers they make
a lot of more purchase I send a roll on
the corner next to the Khan candy yeah
she sings yeah they probably do they
plan to make a letter but yeah really
when they do when they do a test because
I almost worked at a theme park and they
make you have to you would that's it now
that I think about it like I can't
picture myself retirement job I told it
before I'm like when I retire I want to
be one of the drummers in the little
like you know wonder have the like the
little do ops I want to be like the
little drummer not ever gonna be little
anything okay like being a performer in
an a like in a park is like I feel like
an actor or singers worst nightmare
because what they do is they test you
and they want to know you have to do you
have to either be able to do two out of
three
dance sing or act basically so you have
to do two out of the three and then they
audition you they put you through
everything and then at the end of it you
might get placed in a stationary role
where you just have to look pretty so
even though they tested you and you
thought you were gonna be this big
singer and actor and your Winnie the
Pooh yeah and like you have a head mask
on and you're not gonna get recognized
and they hug it down like yeah the hot
stinky ass [ __ ] you I don't know people
should be waiting for the big break at
Disneyland though they are that's the
wrong place to go wrong place to be they
just see it as experience yeah yeah I
see that
I wonder if I hate it though it's like a
really fun thing but inside they just
saw oh no you mean like an actor work
professionally at Disneyland and like
they're a part of the parade and stuff
like bad dancers and stuff yeah you seem
to like the job oh that's good then yeah
sometimes there's that balance you know
yeah alright we're going to Brittany
breakdown 2019 the Britney Spears
everyone this is a look of a conspiracy
theory thing and like you know okay just
saying though I saw to eat the other day
and it was like the older I get the more
I understand Brittany's breakdown is
through
I was like Ozzy I'm gonna shave my head
bring up one time and shave my eyebrows
off so like what though before I get it
can I get the thought process behind
that real quick hi bro I was like I like
we broke up and then I was like that's
it I'm going into a goth phase it was
like outside oh I thought he was like in
love with your eyebrows and you're like
[ __ ] never again because I understand
laughter you break up you shave your
pubic hair and then you have sex I
understand that one wait one actually
shave my eyebrows off became a twitch
streamer and was celibate for like three
years
oh why did you do the opposite thing I
believe by this Real Talk I can't
believe I was in the bathroom with the
razor like don't you get lost and you're
right like I'll be supposed to Ruby oh
yes
stop like when you work out and stuff
dude yeah I mean I certainly wasn't
exercising
oh you dancin in shape well this has a
six-pack of she doesn't even work out
genetics in it okay so so this Britney
Spears fan account basically reported a
while ago you know Britney is in a
mental hospital but then somebody that
was a paralegal that worked in the
office this is very legal by the way cuz
like y'all know I like you just came
from working out of like a law office
this is that the paralegal that worked
in the office involved in the Popstars
legal affairs that's [ __ ] up that's
all the podcast yeah so this this person
like their ship you get fired there's
there's entire programs on how to work
as a Hollywood lawyer but to keep the
things really down though like I was
talking to somebody about this the other
day y'all know Jay Z and Beyonce got
problems but they got a good ass lawyer
and they keep their mouth shut
so whoever's after that whole [ __ ]
salon [ __ ] no one talked about it girl
there we go really elevator when she
kicked jay-z's ass it was all over the
place yes
Solange Beyonce jay-z there was elevator
footage of her smacking jeg ikke no
kickin up and jay-z's just taking it
like he [ __ ] up yeah how long ago was
that last year yeah Wow like three years
ago
oh my bad I don't know time
so this paralegal you know what we're
upset with him but we're going to thank
him for the tea okay so this paralegal
hauled into this britney spears fan
podcast and basically was like hey
that's actually not true britney spears
didn't check herself into the mental
hospital
we think her dad did click so and they
left it on a voicemail which is like
what's uh-oh
stupid because they're just gonna be
like hey this is a legal affair turn
over that voicemail we want to know who
left this so this how do they know that
it was him that i mean they didn't out
the paralegal or anything this is this
is more so about you know Britney's
whatever's going on with her but I'm mad
at that person but also like what if
that was a tactic Oh like a PR and talk
about it oh that's a tactic no I just
thought I thought they had a rivalry so
she's just like I'm gonna just make her
look even more local no I don't think
everyone it was like it was like music
yeah it was a tactic to cover up that
she put herself in the mental hospital
well it looks better when someone forces
you because you're not really crazy yeah
this person supports when someone forces
you I'm still in control yeah exactly I
would feel worse if if I did it I if I
read something that says Britney Spears
checked herself into his hospital I'm
thinking she caught herself yeah yeah
but if someone else checks a getting
crazy you look crazy you saw a ghost and
know whatever you saw a ghost nobody
believes your ass and then he check you
in a mental hospital
you'll be like [ __ ] you man Yeah right
that's what I'm saying this well she
didn't see a ghost if I saw a ghost and
I checked myself in a mental hospital
I'm a little [ __ ] yeah or it's all
perspective Joe I get what you're saying
it's let's move on okay all right all
right I have my righteous ideals but
let's move on what happened then what
happened the anonymous tea-time source
claimed that Spears did not check
herself into the mental hospital earlier
this month they claimed that Spears was
not taking her medication and she's also
not the one that canceled her domination
tour it was her dad a bit canceled
because it's been [ __ ] up her life
yeah so there's like no more no more
honey I love your dad a good dad is her
dad the one that recently passed through
someone's dad recently passed it can't
be because I'm a degenerate who was it
that's true I don't know no cause it
wasn't it family member two people that
are in charge of her it's her dad and
someone else like her old manager or
something really I remember because I
remember reading his name I'm like who
names our kid this like the first name
was answer his last name is wallet
conversation whatever you do I'm like
why don't think they went big or large
big wallet to me that was his name and
so they're saying that he was also like
in charge of like her well-being and
stuff along with her dad so yeah
someone's dad passed yeah no I think cuz
I cancel the tour because of some family
stuff right because I think like well
that's what they're gonna say that's the
PR move okay what was going on you know
so yeah yeah I just saw him here so
answer was up until just this past March
answer was also in charge but in 2008
the core
ordered that her dad and answer has
control over her financial status like
her work kind of stuff so she's still
performing but apparently she's not
mentally okay enough to make her own kid
I told her that Vegas was too soon told
you girl dude I mean once you go to
Vegas you're just collecting money but I
think you know so it's said that this
all started in 2008 look this is
conspiracy Bo's coming out again you
know I'm just putting the pieces
together I mean like it's very possible
that Britney could be like bipolar or
something like that oh yeah she's an
artist
yeah bipolar is so common people act
like it's a [ __ ] disease yeah it's
it's super up probably bipolar I don't
give a [ __ ] one minute I'm in the car
yelling at air the next minute I'm
laughing cuz I heard something funny I
don't give a [ __ ] that's no excuse are
you gonna check yourself in let me tell
you something bad do you know why
Buddhism and meditation and all that
[ __ ] exists because we all have methyl
mental health problems that's why you
think people just came out of it for no
[ __ ] reason I'm pretty sure some
Asian dude was like man I don't know
what's going on with my head I'm getting
[ __ ] up I gotta figure out ways to
calm my anxiety down this was thousands
of years ago and they said I'm just
gonna chill and sit still because I got
a DD [ __ ] that's what happened
that's another shirt okay so Brittany
basically my theory is and also because
they said that she's on medication it
sounds like she might be bipolar or
something and they did say before that
she was oh really
they've said that so it makes sense that
they kind of take her out of the
limelight of like interviews new music
they take all that pressure off her
they're like Brittany just go to Vegas
just make your money perform like that
makes sense Vegas more is more
depressing for an artist than anything
in the world don't they know the police
Celine Dion and Cher's
been doing it amazing - laughs Wow
Celine tried to leave every time she
leaves they add millions more to her
paycheck and she stayed she tried to
leave in like 2009 I got a mate and now
she knows the secret you just threatened
to leave I'd like to cancel my services
now like wait $25 off like that never
works with [ __ ] spectra and they're
like okay well we're sorry to see you go
my [ __ ] there are only [ __ ] option
okay it's the last one so a science
professor taught students how to make
ecstasy whoa like my Cointreau has a
good teacher or bad - I mean yeah people
who are doing it for me I'm pretty sure
they made it on a do you make ecstasy no
that's what I thought I don't know as
that is people that sell it they maybe
also just get a little adderall and
carve a little smiley face well people
buy the powder I've heard of people
stamping it themselves but never I
didn't know people come my friends
life's goal since high school was to
develop drugs and sell them in the black
market he's highly intelligent I think
he's working on his PhD right now oh my
god being drugs
what for good drugs with nobody the
black market oh no personal use
he loves drugs so much new drugs on the
market yet new drugs nothing he's gonna
die one of his experiments
I saw him overdosed twice oh my god pin
like straight to the heart
oh no honey not again Tom used it wisely
though I feel like it could I don't know
like exciting the human possibility
whatever yeah I mean not saying that I'm
not for it really it sounds like you're
no no no
I'm the same possibility drugs just the
wrong man sir the way he the way he
views drugs is very different from us
it's not a it's not like a criminalized
substance right for him it's like these
things exists why don't we use our
intelligent it's to heighten these
sensations and other things yeah
whatever pill or thing that we in I
think where you lost me is once he
wanted to sell it on the black market so
I was with him that was his motivation
maybe that was us in high school right
okay yeah yeah so now you seized he's
doing research he's developing stuff
yeah and all that but the funny thing is
so you know highly intelligent people
they have a they usually have a really
high tolerance for certain things or or
they're able to like like what's the
word consume a lot of [ __ ] cuz they're
like maybe it's like their brain is like
they need a lot of stimulation this guy
will clear out a whole entire gram in
one hit of weed you would [ __ ] know
because I am a big Ram is about this
much but it's a lot it'll last me a
[ __ ] week cuz I don't smoke that much
weed I thought you were gonna say that
much crack I was like this dude he does
so much to make him like I'm just like
how are you not a [ __ ] homeless Mac
crackhead and how are you still
functioning as a human being and doing
research and doing all this [ __ ] I don't
know as his body just got so used to it
but not as much as he did and look at
how I turned out so this guy this is a
this is a professor in Japan so he was
teaching a students how to produce mmm
MDMA to further their knowledge of
pharmaceuticals the only reason he got
caught is because you actually need a
permit to teach like drug making for
pharmaceutical purposes but he hasn't
expired and so what is he yeah he could
actually he could've legal or like
regular form it says Japanese law
requires researchers to obtain a license
from regional authorities to manufacture
illegal drugs for academic
so he got lazy in every new his lies
right and he was at school I'm not sure
but so afterwards he would collect all
of the MDMA to grade them on it I'm
totally kidding semester to get through
the whole class Oh cuz you had to do one
every day you know some new [ __ ] I was
reading about there's using MDMA to help
soldiers with PTSD and therapy I think
you'll work yeah certain like cases I
feel like it helps you know yeah like if
you use it wrong obviously it's gonna be
done I mean I've actually never done
anything anything have a smoked weed
dealer or a cigarette yeah what about
all you want oh yeah my junk at home but
um yeah that's awesome
your unicorn so how do you feel I feel
very well what's it like to not have
done any drugs no I'm yeah it'll be a
separate topic it would be a long thing
but yeah I I think long social yeah I'm
a little worried how far it will go
you're a sex addict that's what it is
some [ __ ] going on by some skeletons in
their closet